so I had honestly planned on finishing
out Jason Aaron's Thor god of thunder
and then jumping into Amazing Spiderman
because it would give us a chance to
kind of go back and you know cover a
bunch of the spider-man stuff going into
life spider-verse and then going into
all-new all-different amazing spider-man
and then it was just kind of ending it
there because you know we'd be pretty
much caught up at that point what you
guys love for you guys are going
absolutely nuts over Thor stuff which
gives me a lot of hope for when we do
all the four videos when Ragnarok comes
around I figured that'd be the best time
to start jumping in like actually
seriously jumping into Thor and doing a
whole lot more than Jason Aaron's run
but after covering you know really the
god bomb storyline what I wanted to do
is cover this one shot and because this
is this is really like a one shot that
comes after a story of that magnitude
because Jason Aaron had spent so much
time with God butcher and God bomb
basically painting this idea that Gore
had believed that all gods are basically
corrupted they were evil they didn't
care about the small guy he painted this
this huge elaborate picture that what he
does is he comes back and basically
paints this image with regards to the
whole you know Thor mythos that Odin's
son is very much a God that cares about
the small guy it's very much a God that
cares about the little people and does
so in spectacular fashion and that's
really what this story focuses on but
this is also a prelude to Jane Foster
picking up the thorn out the hammer of
Thor for the first time so it's actually
a really cool moment and this will be
the story that actually bridges the gap
now there will be a few more things that
we'll cover before we actually cover
because there's really only two videos
and it takes before we're caught up with
the current you know current day of Ford
but there are a few things to take place
here they kind of lead into Jane Foster
gaining a hammer of four but anyway this
story basically picks up with for god of
thunder and with wood Odin Sun actually
going to visit a prison and the reason
why is because he's visiting this guy
now we don't really need to know a whole
lot about this guy I mean he's just a
guy who is in jail but Thor presents him
with something called the fruit of the
candle archery and this is basically
fruit from a whole other world from a
whole other planet but when this guy
takes a bite of it it is the most
delicious thing he's ever had in his
life now the reason why Thor is doing
this is because this man is on his last
meal it's his last rites this man is
going to be executed and so for
basically brings this guy his last meal
now we don't really know the
circumstances surrounding this we don't
know this guy's just said have four give
me like something outrageous from
another planet
or something like that it some was just
the idea the Thor took time out to visit
a guy who was gathered to be summarily
executed and basically gave him this
incredible piece of food so from here we
actually transition over to a to really
three different locations the first is
kind of like this rural town presumably
in Rio de Janeiro those are the favelas
that look like their design in the
background and of course some nuns and
the Dalai Lama with regards to Rio de
Janeiro this is now in really Brazilian
this this area is known to be one of the
most impoverished places that are out
there and thorn actually presents a lot
of the children with some pretty exotic
foods you know with some feast that he's
basically killed and that he's cooking
the cool thing here is that they're all
basically having a barbecue at Thor now
let me tell you something man I bet a
barbecue with Thor is amazing like like
Thor what are you gonna bring for the
barbecue I will bring potatoes salad
it'll be the best potato salad like like
my mother's potato salad from Asgard is
unbelievable like it would be it'd be
amazing food it'd be an amazing barbecue
but notice this I mean this is this is
small stuff he's barbecuing with some
kids in a very impoverished part of the
world he goes to see some nuns he
delivers to them something called the
seeds of the quasar orchid which come
from a from an extinct tree that hasn't
existed for three million years but the
idea is that they can regrow them they
can basically kind of you know bring
Beauty back or at least you know restore
some measure of beauty that has long
been extinct one of the nuns even almost
forgets her vows she literally like
wants to get with for Thor visits the
Dalai Lama
you know this spiritual leader of the
world one of the most recognized
individuals kind of being a place of
peace and so on these are all great
moments at Thor has he shares alcohol
with veterans and he brings water to the
Rio to the deserts I mean this is a guy
who very much focuses on the small
people who spoke with who focused on
people that seemed fly past day in and
day out and that's what makes this so
cool because a lot of stories that
Marvel Comics does and really kind of a
hallmark of a good writer is they'll do
this a lot of the writers will write a
story and they'll be like here's this
grandiose epic and then that that epic
will finish and they'll just move on to
the next one they don't really give us
as the reader a chance to breathe you
know it doesn't give us a chance to kind
of examine the character and see what
the character is really about that's one
of the things that I love so much I mean
Jonathan Hickman did it at least I think
it was taken a might even Mark Waid one
of them did it with Reed Richards like
Reed Richards went to go visit a guy who
was dying or had cancer some along those
lines like I remember but Reed Richards
basically sat with him while the guy was
and the reason why was because we gave
this guy a device and said if you ever
need me contact me the guy contacted him
and said look I'm basically dying and
Reid stayed with him until he died it
was one of the most heartwarming moments
ever in the history of his character but
it was beautifully done but from here we
actually switch over to a character
named Raj Solomon now those of you guys
who are reading for right now
Roth Solomon is well you guys are well
versed in who she is but this is her
introduction for the most part into
Marvel Comics which is to say her really
getting any kind of measure of
recognition and in truth the cool thing
about this is that Ross Solomon had
actually made this crazy request you
know we're just kind of this this insane
request as a cadet and shield somebody
who had recently graduated going on to
become a SHIELD agent with regards to
the you know to environmentalist action
she had made this crazy request that
Thor accompanied her to the cadets ball
and he shows up and that's the craziest
thing is because she's just totally
flabbergasted by the idea depth or would
show up and dance with her so again it's
this really cool thing because what we
actually find out for man this guy's got
some game like Thor spittin some mad
game on rod Solomon and it's the
funniest thing you know because he's
gentlemanly he's very classy he's very
tender he's very gentle and that's the
coolest thing about this is because we
think of Thor's this guy who just like
ransack stuff and beats up people but
he's got like a fifth of whiskey and he
spit in some mad game on rod Solomon and
actually it's really kind of cool to see
but at this point we really kind of
switch it over to really one of the
sadder parts of the entire story and we
actually end up joining Thor visiting
Jane Foster the saddest thing about this
is this is when Jane Foster reveals the
fourth that she has cancer and she's
dying now when this happened it was huge
I mean it was nuts because it would be
like Mary Jane Watson going to Peter
Parker and saying I have cancer or like
Lois Lane going to Superman and saying I
have cancer and I'm dying like Jane
Foster is borz Lois Lane that's was Mary
Jane Parker here is Mary Jane Watson
that's his character I mean that's
that's the woman in his life even if it
didn't always get along together you
know even if they never really like
became a serious romantic couple she was
always the lead woman in his life when
it came to people outside of asgard
because their intrinsic history because
of the fact they've been together for so
long that is to say you know been kind
of the power couple or the power group
of four stories and she's in turn dying
it changed everything now of course this
also deals with the fact that Jane
Foster is married
so on but the coolest thing about this
is the Thor says look I can find a way
to heal you we can take you to Asgard
you know we can find ways to basically
eliminate your cancer now this is kind
of wishful thinking on Forest Park
remember and Marvel Comics cancers
incurable I mean cancer is as incurable
and Marvel Comics as it is in the real
world the Oh for example when it came to
the character of Marvel you know the
original Marvel of the Kree he was
killed off because he had cancer Danice
was the one that escorted him to the
afterlife it was one of the very few
moments in Marvel Comics when Thanos
just stops being a bad guy and it's just
like you are an honorable adversary I
fought against you time and time again
you know this passing will be something
that I will help you with I will help
accompany you to the realm of mistress
death beautifully written stories is
absolutely one of the best stories that
I've ever seen it was just an incredible
story it's right up there with like
Silver Surfer Requiem in terms of all
the fields that you get when you're
reading it but it's incredibly well done
but this is much the same way Thor
offers things like hey you know we can
cure you and it's possible that that's
the best available Avenue for Jane
Foster to take but ultimately she
doesn't ultimately she doesn't take that
road instead she simply says no this is
something that people all over the world
struggle with this is something that
people have seen everywhere I will deal
with it the best way that I can now this
is Jason Aaron doing a couple of things
it's Jason Aaron basically saying hey
look uh we're setting the stage for Jane
Foster to become four you know we are
setting the stage remains you're going
to have a ticking clock for a character
because we know that right now in Marvel
Comics Jason Aaron is a writer that
always or at least always seems to focus
on the end game meaning that here is a
set of events that happen now the watch
starts and when this watch hits zero
that story comes to an end and all the
characters in it will come to their most
logical lines of conclusion but Jane
Foster the most logical line of
conclusion is that she will probably die
and so the idea here with regards to the
current iteration of Thor for those of
you guys who might find yourselves a
little confused is Jane Foster undergoes
chemotherapy in order to basically rid
herself of her cancer the problem is
that whenever she transforms into Thor
it flushes the chemotherapy out of her
system and so if she undergoes a round
of chemo and then immediately transforms
into Thor she might as well have not had
that chemo in the first place her cancer
will just continue progressing and so
what this does it is again you know
Jason Aaron kind of setting the stage
and saying when the time comes when I
put my pin down and I say okay we are
now done it will likely result in Jane
pause
dying and Odin's son becoming Thor again
which is kind of sad to see because if
I'm gonna be honest with you guys I
think Jane Foster's had some of the best
Thor storytelling there's ever been
I mean it's she's probably one of the
most interesting iterations of Thor that
I've ever seen in comics and I think
it'll be a sad day when she's not for
anymore but the badge remains here that
ultimately you know where Jane Foster
just says no Thor honors her wishes he
honors her desire to say okay look I
will go ahead and stay hands-off but you
have to keep in mind this is crushing
for for Thor never really comes across
an adversary that he can't be you know
he'll fight until the Bennet into the
bitter end
even if it means his own death he'll
keep fighting and fighting and fighting
until he wins sometimes that adversary
is physical it's Galactus is ego the
Living Planet its gore the god butcher
other times it's metaphorical it's an
illness that someone has but to be told
no you cannot fight this battle is
denying Thor his own nature and what it
does is it loserman estate a feeling
absolutely helpless and that's the
craziest thing about this because Jane
Foster just takes away the one thing
that he wants to do and so if the offer
that's made is look if I cannot help rid
you of your cancer then allow me to do
something to make your day a little bit
better allow me to do something to show
you how much I care as a print and so
what they do is they go to the blue area
of the moon and for those you guys don't
know the blue area of the moon and
Marvel Comics is an area that doesn't
exist in the real world but isn't it's
an area of the moon that has oxygen
meaning that's the reason why if you
read stories where they talk about we
were at the blue area of the moon or you
see a battle on the moon and nobody has
any suits on it's because it's the one
area of the Moon where they can continue
breathing and a lot of people occupy
this space or they have over the course
of Marvel Comics The Watcher for example
has been around this area the Inhumans
have taken up residence in this area
when x-factor D Inhumans and the x-men
joined forces and fought apocalypse they
fought on the blue area of the moon and
so the blue area has been used quite a
few times in Marvel Comics and it's
always kind of cool to see but what
happens the reason why they're here is
because they're basically watching the
Sun rise over Earth and so it's really
the only great gift that Thor can give
to Jane Foster you know as it stands
right now and of course we'll see you
play a more prominent role and the realm
of the Thor landscape especially when it
comes to the Congress of worlds or the
Congress of realms and what-have-you and
it's really kind of a cool thing to see
but in any event I thought I'd go ahead
and bring this to you guys because it's
short you know it's a really quick story
it's really cool I mean it's just a one
shot it's one comic book but it's really
really interesting because it focuses on
the fact that Thor is not the God that
Gore hated so much he's not a God that
ignores people he's out to God it
doesn't care you know he's a God that
focuses very much on the small guys it's
just presumably it happens off panel we
just don't really see it that often but
with that being said guys if you are new
here two comments explained make sure
you guys took the sub button to become
part of the rod core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]